well John I am very sorry
for my strong response to a comment that was meant to be nice
I do um usually assume men are being mean
cause that's been my experience
so thank you for um
explaining I apologize
appreciate you and your um
contribution
so truly I'm sorry
if I'm gonna call you out all big and loud
I will apologize big and loud
so thank you for being a kind voice
and I'm sorry
like truly I'm sorry
I wasn't trying to come at you
but I did just want to use it as a talking point
like if somebody was saying it in a nasty way
but that doesn't give it
you know what I mean
I'm not trying to justify what I did
I'm just saying I misunderstood
I'm sorry I'm sorry